HBO max has pulled Gone with the Wind
from its library of movies a bill
available for streaming the 1939
oscar-winning epic has long been
criticized for its depiction of
african-americans and form romanticizing
the Confederacy an HBO spokesperson says
the movie will return to the streaming
service with a discussion of its
historical context and an announcement
of those very depictions in Anthony this
all started with an op-ed in the LA
Times by 12 years of slave writer John
Ridley but we should point out that John
really is not calling for the film to be
censored and actually a statement by HBO
and how the film could eventually return
was one of the course of actions that he
suggested yeah yeah I mean this is Vlad
this is really kind of Hollywood's first
major blockbuster at one eight Oscars I
think adjusted for inflation it's still
the highest grossing film of all time
Hattie McDaniel who you saw in the
pictures there won an Oscar for playing
mammy which was the house slave and and
what the criticism has long been that it
glorifies the antebellum south which it
does but I so I think I totally agree I
think it should be good in some real
context here after all this time